it is just after 1600 GMT 11 A.M in
Washington and that's where President
Joe Biden has officially welcomed French
president Emmanuel macron on his first
state visit since Biden took office the
leaders are expected to discuss the war
in Ukraine and China and Iran but France
will also raise concerns about Joe
Biden's climate and infrastructure Bill
earlier Macomb criticized subsidies in
the bill saying that they are quote
super aggressive towards European
companies
let's go to our White House
correspondent Kimberly halket Kimberly
you are going to spend the entire day
watching the pump and the pageantry
because that is the nature of State
visits what has stood out to you so far
well what stood out is the fact that the
White House is really trying to focus on
the fact that this is an important visit
and highlighting the importance of the
relationship and so the red carpet has
been rolled out the gifts have been
exchanged and there really is an
elaborate ceremony that has been taken
place that it really is highlighting the
importance of the relationship that goes
back throughout history and this is
something that has been underscored by
both leaders the U.S president saying
that this is one of America's oldest
allies an unwavering partner saying that
the flame of Liberty is essential for
our mutual defense and also that
Emmanuel macron's underscoring the
United States is an essential partner
when it comes to France saying that now
that war has returned to the European
soil that the partnership is once again
integral to to the security saying that
there is a need for the United States of
France to be brothers in arms once more
so well there is a tremendous symbolism
in terms of the Pomp and the pageantry
there also is very serious tone to all
of this in the fact that this is is very
much a relationship that is is bonded in
security as well when do they get to the
harder conversations right the ones that
take place behind closed doors and this
year it might be about subsidies my core
has not been shy about saying they
helped the U.S but they hurt Europe
yeah that difficult conversation is
taking place as we speak and you're
right uh there has been some very blunt
criticism coming from the French
President to almost immediately when he
touched down he said that a signature
policy of this President Joe Biden
something known as the inflation
reduction act in the words of Emmanuel
macro is something that could fragment
the West what he's talking about are
some
subsidies essentially and uh green
energy that is tucked into the inflation
reduction act that essentially are
billions of dollars that will ensure
that not only are these uh green Energy
Technologies uh going to take place but
that a lot of it will be made in America
the fear for many European nations is
that this looks a lot like protectionism
this looks a lot like this could ignite
a trade war and so this is a very big
concern and this is something that needs
to be worked out and this is something
that the European nations want to try
and combat against so this is a very big
deal and it also comes on the heels of a
bit of a diplomatic uproar that took
place very early on in Joe Biden's
presidency and that is the rift that
took place when Australia blindsided
France by nuclear-powered submarines
from the United States instead of from
France a deal that really was something
that blindsided the French President so
there are a bit of some uncomfortable
moments that took place then and are
taking place now as we say behind closed
doors but again for the cameras it is
very much smiles and pop and pageantry
something that will be culminated at the
end of the day with a very formal State
dinner all right Kimberly from the White
House thank you so much we'll check in
again with you next hour RC what you've
been able to glean perhaps from what's
going on behind those closed doors thank
you